so i actually want to talk about one
more thing because we're getting we're
getting close super chat time but uh
yeah
we were talking about woke college
campus all these jokes and it reminds me
of a man jerry seinfeld
because he's the one who kind of sparked
a lot of this conversation around
college campus comedy
and now he's in the news because he's
the one saying new york is fine
yes we're seeing a bunch of articles we
got uh i think you mentioned this
earlier we got the story from uh
the post actually from james how do you
pronounce the name altitude yes james
ultra is my friend too
he said new york city is dead forever
yeah is he right
well this is kind of a it's the truth is
who knows and even james doesn't know
necessarily but i
the first thing is first i saw i've
never seen anything with more hate like
anything i've done
anything a lot of my friends have done
where people go the whole internet goes
you're the worst
the only thing i've seen like this was
when eric shaffer did the kobe thing and
everyone on the internet was like
this guy's basically when he said new
york city is dead forever
people basically saw it as if he went to
the twin towers the day they came down
and spit on the ashes geez
people you i don't know if you were
following this at all but the amount of
visceral hate
i was i was doing comedy shows in new
york still and i would talk to comics
the people be talking about and they go
dick is an idiot like
there was a snad yeah so anyway so jerry
seinfeld i guess was like that and then
he goes
it's not uh dead you're an idiot like
you're wrong like f you
you're stupid you're a putt you call
them a putts which is pretty funny
james aldrich is going back to him he
goes at least jerry seinfeld wrote some
new jokes like stuff like that wow
so ultracher's taken some pretty
contrarian takes here
he's sort of saying here's my list of
what i think he's doubled down since
people got mad at him
i don't know how much of this you know
you know when you make a video every
week he does two articles a week
he may have been kind of being
hyperbolic and not realizing how much
he's putting it out
i agree with him i mean i'm not in new
york so i'm sure people
but but i think seinfeld doesn't know he
didn't he didn't say any good rebuttals
he just goes
no it's not you know he doesn't even
live there no he don't even live there
he's in the hamptons and stuff right so
i mean you live there i live there now
i'm in the thick dude is it dead i'm
full canadian american patriot right now
i love it what do you think i mean
living there in the city
i've been saying that it's funny because
every every as we were talking a little
bit before but everywhere you
everywhere you look on the tv it's like
everyone's locked in their house is the
pandemic
if i go outside my house it's a carnival
there is literally
uh guys selling stuff on the street
everyone's walking around without a mask
no one cares
for the most part there's so they
basically said okay we're gonna let bars
do street bars
if you go to certain corners like in the
east village it's like new orleans
the basically the streets walk blocked
off there's a street party everyone's
having a
everyone's like partying on the street
so there's
well you can't get evicted right yeah i
don't know if that's true yeah you can
you get evicted i don't know
probably i mean i think if a landlord
came up to you and they're like yo
you're evicted you're like yeah i'm not
going anywhere so right right right
go sue me i guess yeah go to go to the
landlord courts and then the landlord
cards would be like yeah i mean there's
a nine-month waiting list and even then
probably not and you'd be like i think
you would just have to eat it if your
tenant stopped paying rent
yeah well i think that's that's one of
the big one of the big challenges now
for one thing people are buying on
properties like crazy they're definitely
they're definitely leaving new york
they're leaving california
san francisco's got like a 96 inventory
increase from people fleeing the city
yeah but people are leaving and so it's
like when i read this article saying new
york was dead
and then i read all these things like
the amount of businesses that are
permanently closed
the half a million middle to upper class
people who have fled already not to
mention that more are leaving inventory
for
you know 13 000 empty empty apartment
buildings
or vacant buildings i believe and then
you got homeless people being put in
these hotels in like the upper east and
west side like these these richer air
like
wealthier areas yeah people are just
like no i sort of misinterpreted your
last question i thought you meant what's
it like in general
i actually forgot that we were relating
it back to this article of whether oh
new york is dead yeah yeah i mean no no
no i think i think what you said is
interesting
yeah but i think that it is true that a
lot of the points he made and there is
this thing where
how long can you push it and push and
push i mean this would happen to silicon
valley right
they go and i think a lot of what james
thinks june not putting words in his
mouth is like when joe rogan kind of
said like all right la
enough's enough i'm out of here right
yeah and whether that had to do with tax
break who knows right
but eventually and people kind of don't
think it has anything to do with text
maybe not right so
i think a lot of people kind of got it
they're like yo la's been pushing their
luck right
they've just said you know we can do
whatever we want because we're los
angeles and everyone wants to live here
and new york kind of feels like that too
we'll have way higher taxes and fu
everyone still wants to be
here and there's a point where it's like
everything else is opening back up
people have started working remotely and
they like it and it works and you go
this is better
so there is a there is a point where
there is
where other places start looking more
attractive and then everyone moved to
silicon valley from
to austin and now austin they're
starting to regulate and do all this
stuff and
they're kind of like all right we gotta
find a new place seems like the people
that like freedom and not regulation
kind of always go on the run
then those places get good then everyone
comes there and then they crack down
again
i can't find somewhere else to go i
can't believe so i keep hearing from so
many people they're moving to austin
and i'm like that's exactly why i'm not
gonna do it yeah austin
it's good i think the people that moved
austin the peter teals of the world
well i don't know if you move there but
the hymns of the world that are like
silicon valley's out of control the
group conformity is too much
the innovation's dying because the reg
whatever it is right housings are too
high all of the stuff right
so they basically all moved austin my
like it seems like over the last four or
three
you know years kind of thing and then
now it's sort of caught up where
austin's back to where
silicon valley is now right right you
know i think it's south by southwest too
because i i remember the first time i
went to south by i was so excited i got
invited to speak
yeah and then i was like this is a lie
the whole thing was a lie
like nobody no nobody cared about
anything going on it was just an excuse
to go hang out with your buddies it was
like all these silicon valley dudes
getting drunk
and i was like that's cool if that's
your thing dude that's like burning man
you're like yeah this cool hippie thing
and you're like everyone here works on
wall street
yeah and you show up and they're like in
luxury that's why i i have friends who
are like i love going to burning man and
i'm like
they did a quiznos commercial there dude
yeah i'm sorry man
that's why i'm i'm like look i'm gonna
hang out with some guy a silicon valley
guy and this dude with moon shoes and
dreadlocks on
yeah no no no you know you know what i
think would be really cool and i think
we need is people need to go make their
own places
i was looking at a bunch of really small
towns in the middle of nowhere that were
dying out yeah that's kind of what
you're doing a little bit right
a little bit um but you're only one step
away from seasteading
well i mean that'd be cool too do the
tim pool complex just get like a big
mega yeah and just go off and be like
armed guards and you know fight off
pirates
no but like it wouldn't it wouldn't be
cool if you know all these rich people
they're going to austin and i'm like but
why
it's it's it's going to you give it 10
years and it'll be exactly what you left
because all these people are rushing
they're like i want to go somewhere
that's cool and hip and california's
gross
and it's like dude california had one
party rule forever they have a super
majority in la and they couldn't pass
any of these reforms to fix their
problems
and all these people are going to go to
austin who don't care about austin
they're going to go to these areas of
texas they don't care about texas and
you're gonna get the same problem
people move to la they're not from la so
they don't care about the community's
problems
so they just they pass they pass the
buck la falls to crap and they move
again
they bounce around it's like it's it's
like the aliens from independence day
you know
you see that movie they just like they
come to earth because they're going to
strip it clean of resources and then
leave yeah so i'm just like no i mean i
do get that because
i'm not from new york and there's all
this you know when people are like
can you believe he said that about new
york and i was like what do i care like
i'm
canadian i'm like you know i'm here
because it's like a good place to do
stand-up and it is a hub of the world
for culture and i think
the best comedy in the world is
happening there especially right now was
yeah exactly i'm half kidding i'm half
kidding but you're right dude you're
right yeah
what was that story where like a comedy
club did an outdoor event they got shut
down yeah that's up i mean there
they basically allowed them and then
they shut them down so i got like an
email last week from a lot of people
being like yeah that show's canceled
that's so dumb you know yeah here's what
i'm saying they're they're pushing their
luck that's what they're saying they go
you know no one's going anywhere and
everyone's like yeah we kind of will
though you know
go to i don't know in nebraska or
something
there's there's tons of open space dude
people build your own place yeah you're
moving like people will move for what
they want to do i mean i just did
like i was in toronto i didn't like the
way that it was shaking down there i saw
something here and i
felt like i could make a better life and
yeah so i see
this exactly what i'm talking about
right see these people and these
communists in california move to austin
and this guy is like you a canadian
communist
i'm just kidding but but uh no but it is
actually kind of funny i want half your
views on this
we should split the views yeah no yes
they are they're my views our views
now let's get these super chat since i'm
taking half of the money when
when did you come down from uh from
canada less than a year ago so before
covid
yeah so i was here whack timing right
he snuck in yeah dude i got um i came
here
uh and then i did like four or five
months you know enough to make some
you know meet people and getting all
these comedy clubs and then boom coven
so
wow tonight trapped yeah it's okay i
like new york i mean
lots of cool stuff's happening right now
so it's it's fine man i mean people are
innovative right it's like even this go
back to listen like what happened in the
last little while the industry was so
uh we only want this one type of thing
and then look at people like you that
created your whole little empire here
right and i mean same thing
the whole podcasting empire like all of
those people would have had tv shows
five years ago but they're like we don't
want this type of guy on tv it's like
you know they essentially people are
very inventive and
especially the certain they're you know
one i would say like 100 people in
america
has the values of like i'm gonna
accomplish what i would like to do
no matter what and if you even at one in
a hundred
that's you know three million people
that are willing to do anything to get
what they want right
so if you say okay we don't want this
type of comedy it's like okay we'll
create our own thing and
there's a lot of people that are that
are uh willing to do any whatever it
takes in america and i think that's one
of the things i like about it here
so do you think these big industry like
so so netflix did have a rogan special
dated dave chappelle special
do you think those are the but those are
legacy people right like there is
exactly where you get so big and you
know the truth is i even disagree with
not
necessarily rogan but the way ricky
gervais talks about cancer culture and
jokes i i disagree with him like
because his take on that sort of thing
is always oh it's just jokes like you
should be able to joke about anything
but a lot of times i'm saying these
jokes and my audience knows i'm
ironic and they actually know the right
opinions yeah so he basically says
and i know if you're in that position he
might you need to say no i'm one of the
good guys
i'm just making jokes but the truth is
when ricky gervais says that he's like
you know let's say he has a whole thing
making fun of caitlyn jenner like saying
that she's not actually hot or whatever
right
yeah and they go okay they're not
laughing at that because they actually
know what's wrong
they're laughing at that because it's a
little bit true and they know they're
not supposed to laugh at it yeah
and there's a lot of components to the
formula one of them being they're not
supposed to
one of them being like it's a little bit
true but you're not supposed to say it
and it's sometimes they are
laughing at something that uh is like
obviously not true
you know like if i said like oh yeah i'm
just very racist like everyone's like
he's obviously being ironic or whatever
yeah so but the way that they talk about
it is they go no i'm playing a character
and my audience is so not racist that
everyone knows
and it's like sometimes but sometimes
you're saying uncomfortable truths and
that's why you're getting like a laugh
of people being like that is kind of
true
and they don't take credit for that and
because they don't take credit for that
other people kind of uh you know kind of
end up having to
play in a dishonest ballpark because so
i'd rather some of those people just
like just stay out of it if you're gonna
lie thanks for checking out this clip
from the tim cast irl podcast we do the
show live
monday through friday at 8 pm if you
want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or
check us out on itunes and spotify and
we will soon have this podcast up for
free
on all podcast platforms thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next episode
you